війна в Україні дещо змінила західні
Альянс у Європі Алену у всіх випадках
яскравим винятком є угорський лідер
Віктор Орбан який не хоче постачати
зброю Києву Та не дозволяє її транзит
через свою країну Ні Гість із Будапешта
речник прем'єр-міністра урбана
золотанкувач ви хочете щоб Зеленський
виграв цю війну Ми хочемо миру Ви не
хочете щоб він переміг чого б це не
коштувало і як би це не було досягнуто
Навіть якщо це Мирна умова Москви щоб не
відбувалося в Україні Це не добре не
лише для Угорщини а й для Європи чому ж
уряд Угорщини Вважають що Путін зробив
Росію з новою великою
Ласкаво просимо до конфлікт з ООН дякую
за запрошення
почнімо з війни в Україні що у березні
ваш прем'єр-міністр заявив що відповідь
на питання над чиєму боці Угорщина
звучить так Угорщина на боці Угорщини і
це ще не все ви зробили і сказали багато
чого на радість вашим друзям у Москві ви
граєте роль троянського коня Росії
всередині НАТО
Коли ставити запитання будь ласка
правильно цитуйте тому що початок цього
речення був таким що ми за мир
Угорщина була однією з перших країн яка
негайно закликала до припинення вогню та
миру до негайних мирних переговорів тому
що це єдиний спосіб яким можна
спробувати вирішити цей конфлікт і
справді щоб хтось не казав під час війни
кожна держава-член НАТО завжди
представляє насамперед власні інтереси
цілком очевидно У нас є спільні інтереси
як у членів НАТО оборонного Альянсу
Також ми сусіди України варто було б
цього почати звісно ми маємо
зобов'язання коли в сусідній країні
вирує війна і люди тікають рятуючи своє
життя Отже такою є наша позиція у цьому
конфлікті
я не применшую обсяги допомоги яку ви
надали українським біженцям вона була
значною але Подивіться на ваші дії
категорична відмова надавати Україні
будь-яку зброю чи дозволити НАТО
провозити зброю для України через Москва
мабуть була в захваті від цього чи не
так
щодо Москви ми не знаємо І власне Нам
все одно що думають у Москві про це
говорили і прем'єр-міністр і Багато
наших провідних політиків що для нас
дійсно важливо як для країни сусіда
України в якій проживає значна Угорська
меншина 150 тисяч людей то це те що
будь-яке постачання зброї будь-яка
участь у поставках зробить цю меншість
як і Угорщину мішенню згадайте інцидент
у Польщі Ми всі знаємо що всі сусідні з
Україною України можуть випадково чи
навмисно стати стороною конфлікту Якщо
не будуть обережними позиція Угорщини
щодо постачання зброї завжди була дуже
чіткою ми не беремо участь у конфлікті
Ми за мир якщо в Центральній Європі йде
збройний конфлікт для угорців це завжди
погано Не кажучи вже про тих кого
безпосередньо торкнулися війна чи то на
південь від Угорщини чи в даному випадку
на північний схід від Угорщини тож
повторюся це дуже послідовне угорський
підхід до збройних конфліктів у регіоні
можливо це послідовний підхід Але якщо
ви так сильно хочете Миру Чому ви не
сказали що Москва має вивести свої
війська з України Ми таки зробили
Угорщина однією з перших засудили
агресію ми неодноразово вимагали та
вимагаємо негайного перемир'я виведення
військ та припинення збройного конфлікту
Це очевидно порушення міжнародного права
і я вважаю що прем'єр-міністр Міністр
закордонних справ наш парламент наша
президентка яка нещодавно відвідала
Україну недвозначно говорили про природу
війни та природу агресії в Україні
Так але те що ви пропонуєте це саме те
чого хотіла Москва заморозити конфлікт
допоки Кремль має перевагу і може
закріпити свої територіальні завоювання
у будь-якому разі чому Україна має сісти
за стіл так званих переговорів і здати
територію ворожому загарбникові який
бомбардує руйнує її міста та села та
вбиває її людей Чому вона має вести
мирні переговори тому що мирні
переговори та діалог - Це єдиний спосіб
вийти з конфлікту ні є інший вихід із
конфлікту полягає в тому щоб Росія
вивела свої війська з України війська
які вона перш за все не повинна була
туди вводити
але З усією повагою і без спекуляцій є
тільки один спосіб витіснити їх і знову
ж таки цей конфлікт у сусідній країні не
новий він триває з 2014 року коли
відбулася незаконна анексія Криму
санкційна політика та позиція більшої
частини західної Європи Сполучених
Штатів та нато не сприяли завершенню
цього конфлікту тобто такий підхід не
зміг зупинити конфлікт він лише
посилився тому повторюся потрібні
належні мирні переговори та втручання
якого ми не бачимо з боку лідерів
Європейського Союзу щоб зняти напругу
між ворогуючими сторонами та спробувати
зробити щось для врегулювання
розбіжностей Це був би вихід
але як ви вважаєте який мир Москва
реально могла б підписати з Україною
коли величезна кількість російських
військ окупували значну територію
України
зіткнувшись із сильним суперником
Україна не мала б іншого вибору окрім як
вести переговори про власну капітуляцію
і ви знали це від початку
але насправді ніхто навіть не спробував
Ось у чому справа
так Олена це є причина ніхто не хоче
закріпити ситуацію на користь Москви чи
не так ми вважаємо що найефективні
політичні рішення зокрема політика
санкцій особливо в галузі енергетики не
знижують напруженість і не є виходом із
конфлікту скоріше вони сприяють
ескавації Угорщина однозначно
висловилися про санкційну політику та
про свою політичну позицію як сусідньої
країни Ми невеликий гравець на цьому
полі але ми сусіди України звісно
набагато більше її значніші гравці
намагаються зробити Угорщину виною чому
саме Угорщина не зупиняє або не
допомагає зупинити війну це не
виправдані закиди повторюю позиція
Угорщини дуже зрозуміла не намагайтеся
сказати нам що ми перешкоджаємо зусиллям
зі встановлення миру в Україні ми чітко
висловлюємо свою позицію Ми не ховаємося
у нас немає жодних сумнівів Ми хотіли б
щоб так вчиняли насправді хто провокує
напруженість а не знімає її
Чому ви постійно применшуєте значення
близьких відносин між Володимиром
Путіним і вашим прем'єр-міністром у
минулому ви говорили що тісних
політичних зв'язків які приписують
прем'єр-міністру та російському
президентові немає відносини між Росією
та Угорщиною не тісніше ніж у Росії та
Німеччиною Але ж це не зовсім так
дуже проста причина те що ви намагаєтеся
сказати немає жодних підстав зв'язки
відносини Угорщини з Росією не більше
інтенсивні або особливі ніж якщо вже на
то пішло були чи є з Німеччиною 12
зустрічей за 13 років між лідерами 12
зустрічей навіть перебуваючи в Москві 1
лютого за три тижні до вторгнення Росії
Віктор Урбан сказав це наша 12 зустріч
це велика рідкість Він говорив про це з
гордістю це дивно Чи порахували ви
зустрічі розмови і переговори з
німецькими французькими італійськими та
іншими лідерами ви цього не зробили
Причина в тому що коли у вас є Скажімо
так стратегічне партнерство з державою
яка постачає вам сировину енергетичні
ресурси газ і нафту що є історичною
спадщиною це не вина не результат
діяльності цього уряду що з історичних
причин існує майже одностороння
залежність від Російської енергетики то
в такому разі потрібно мати правильні
стосунки які допомага можуть зробити
відносини контрольованими стосунки
можуть вважатися особливими Як ви
говорили лише в цьому контексті але коли
ваша держава залежить від російського
газу на 65% від нафти більш ніж на 80 Я
вважаю що потрібно обережність
Тобто Це ваш пріоритет чи не так у
жодному разі не ставити під загрозу
постачання енергоносіїв із Росії це ваш
Пріоритет у цьому конфлікті
говорити що хтось має моральну перевагу
чи моральний підхід в жодному разі я
Просто намагаюся прояснити який у вас
пріоритет
це дуже просто пріоритет - це інтереси
Угорщини угорського народу Вони
полягають у тому щоб мати надійність
стосунки з цими країнами
насправді ми підтримуємо зв’язки з
нашими партнерами в торгівлі постачання
енергоносіїв це дуже безпечне Угорська
позиція коли моя членами НАТО яка
ґрунтується на взаємній повазі А коли
економіка країни та саме її існування
включаючи домашні господарства Якщо
говорити про енергетику залежить від
ресурсів які надходять із Росії треба
бути дуже обережним тому що будь-який
крок У неправильному напрямку по суті
означає негайно зупинку економіки
був у Москві як я вже говорив 1 лютого
за три тижні до початку вторгнення Росії
то була миротворча місія він
характеризував її як миротворчу місію Як
ви вважаєте чому вона з тріском
провалилася
якби це був провал ну вона ж не принесла
Миру візит не приніс Миру через три
тижні почалося вторгнення
і Пан макрон і пан Шульц також зазнали
невдачі тож повторюся Угорщина знає своє
місце у міжнародних відносинах як я вже
казав ми знаємо що ми особливо з
військової точки зору чи з погляду
безпеки ми маленька країна і наш простір
для маневру політичні інструменти дуже
обмежені я пояснив вам що коли нам
доводиться покладатися на превеликий
жаль через відсутність інфраструктурних
інвестицій з боку західноєвропейських
країн ЄС доводиться покладатися на
постачання енергоносіїв з дерев то ми
маємо зважати на те що відбувається
прем'єр-міністр володіючи дуже глибокими
історичними знаннями та 30-річним
політичним досвідом точно знає як чинити
в подібних ситуаціях у нас немає впливу
на таку велику державу як Росія так само
як на Німеччину чи Францію тому коли ми
намагаємося говорити про мир цілком
очевидно що не угорські плани пропозиції
міркування вплинули на те що вирішила
зробити Росія
через 4 роки після того як Путін захопив
Крим про який ви говорили трохи раніше і
розпалив війну на Донбасі Віктор горбан
похвалив російського лідера заявивши в
2018 році що потрібно визнати що Путін
знову зробив свою країну великою і що
Росія знову стала гравцем на світовій
арені що такого великого в країні яка
розпочинає незаконні вторгнення дедалі
сильніше придушує права людини та вбиває
своїх політичних опонентів у середині
країни та за кордоном що у цьому
Великого
за всією поваги слова прем'єр-міністра
абсолютно правдиві це те що ми бачимо
сьогодні Росія відновила силу претендує
на відновлення впливу та розпочала війну
ми знаємо що то була агресія ми знаємо
що вона була невиправданою і конфлікту
Можна було б запобігти якби
західноєвропейські лідери визнали все
хто міг би запобігти цьому конфлікту
припускаю що ті сили які якби сказати
можуть зрівнятися за силою та впливом з
Росією але за всією поваги фраза
прем'єр-міністра абсолютно правдива це
те що ми бачимо це є велич вбивства та
репресій в Росії вас анітрохи не
турбують це те ж ознака вилачі чи не так
Ви можете мати свою думку якими маємо
свою думку про те що відбувається і як і
що ми думаємо про це але це не змінює
того факту що те про що говорив
прем'єр-міністр має місце нині
чому спочатку війни ваш уряд здається зі
шкіри геть лізе щоб зробити приємність
Кремлю чому ви наполягали на тому щоб
патріарх російської Православної Церкви
Кирило був виключений зі списку санкцій
ЄС незважаючи на його активне сприяння
та підтримку війни
якщо йдеться про санкційну політику
особливо коли йдеться про осіб
пов'язаних із церквами то це питання
принципу угорський уряд завжди чітко
усвідомлював сумнівно доцільність
санкційної політики якщо йдеться про
політичні Не кажучи вже про військові
цілі починаючи з 2014 року адже Ось у
2022 році після стількох років
санкційної політики триває війна якщо
йдеться про церковних діячів ми вважаємо
що тут проходить межа тож якщо ви
почнете вводити санкції проти церковних
лідерів де ви зупинитесь хто ухвалює ці
рішення Якщо ви хочете накласти санкції
на окремих людей є інші підходи та інші
можливості досягти бажаної мети крім як
покарання за їхню релігійну позицію чи
накладання санкцій на церкви Як це
пропонувалося
повернімося до війни НАТО хоче щоб
Зеленський виграв війну ваш Прем'єр
називає його опонентом НАТО надсилає все
більше і більше ви думаєте що Альянс
затягує війну ви хочете щоб Зеленський
виграв війну
Ми хочемо миру Ви не хочете щоб він
переміг чого б це не коштувало і як би
це не було досягнуто Навіть якщо це
Мирна умовах Москви
хоч би що відбувалося в Україні Це не
добре не лише для Угорщини а і для
Європи ви бачите що відбувається ви
бачите що насувається інфляція та
економічна криза це криза яка є
наслідком поганих політичних рішень а не
реальності А це брак сировини й
економічна криза відповідно до глав
західноєвропейських держав і
західноєвропейського мислення причини
полягають у витоках нинішньому стані і
майбутньому цієї війни ми тут у
центральній Європі особливо як сусід
України обрали інший шлях А саме ми
Закликаємо до негайного перемир’я мирних
переговорів і припинення бойових дій
тому що це єдиний вихід із конфлікту
Я це розумію але як член НАТО ви не
можете змусити себе сказати що хочете
Перемоги України Росія була агресором ви
це визнали але не можете сказати що
хочете Перемоги України
альянсом і НАТО має дійти до спільного
рішення щодо України тож те що ви бачите
від імені держави-члена це інша справа
Ми підтримуємо наших союзників по НАТО і
ми завжди дотримувалися і будемо
дотримуватися спільних рішень НАТО
на Ковач раді були бачити вас у
конфліксоуон Велике спасибі за розмову
дякую
[музика]